what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the latest twist in the
blog clover story a twist that involved
hasta falling into a major trap set by a
character that has been built up as one
of the most powerful characters in the
history of black clover this mysterious
and highly suspicious queen of the heart
kingdom is determined to get her hands
on austin's demon and we have no idea
whether she intends to simply take
Oscars grimoire or actually kill hasta
in the process furthermore Noel Finn
Rahl and mimosa are currently facing off
against the character that is using
mysterious heart Kingdom powers powers
that are not the same as the
conventional magic of the clover kingdom
after a lengthy build-up in the previous
chapters this most recent chapter really
accelerated the action and the stakes
are really high and that is exactly what
I will be talking about in this video if
you enjoy the black clover content here
on the channel please leave a like to
let me know and if you happen to be new
to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications unless you
go through the trouble of not only
subscribing but also hitting the bell
and turning on all notifications you
will not be notified when we upload new
videos unfortunately that is just how
YouTube works nowadays you can also
follow me on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest black
clover news and updates and finally this
video will of course feature spoilers
from the black clover manga I will be
discussing all of the latest happenings
in the manga so please proceed with
caution you have been warned chapter 2
to 5 starts off with hasta and the crew
still admiring the incredible natural
beauty of the Hart Kingdom it really is
impressive to see all this Amazon
rainforest esque greenery coexisting in
harmony with man-made structures and
settlements and this coexistence seems
to be a defining feature of the Hart
Kingdom itself I honestly can't wait to
see the Hart Kingdom animated in the
anime I think that when all the
appropriate colors are added the anime
will really bring to life the natural
beauty of the heart king
in a totally new way as much as I
personally preferred to black clover
manga to the anime overall I do look
forward to seeing this specific part of
the manga covered in the anime as FINRA
wonders where exactly would be a good
place to dock their boat a man suddenly
appears on the boat itself seemingly out
of nowhere this man who has a big scar
on his face and who was wearing clothing
that is clearly different from the
popular fashion of the clover Kingdom
introduces himself as Gaia of the spirit
guard and he says that he will be their
guide through the heart Kingdom by the
way his name is spelled G a J a so there
are various ways that it could be
potentially pronounced you could
pronounce it as Gaja in English you
could pronounce it as gah ha in Spanish
and so on
the reason I'm just gonna call him Gaia
is because in many languages in Europe
including my own language serbian a J is
actually pronounced as a Y and not only
that but in Greek mythology Gaia same
pronunciation but different spelling is
the personification of the earth since
the Hart kingdom is so heavily focused
on nature and coexisting with Mother
Earth I'm gonna assume that this guy's
name is actually a reference to Gaia I
could be wrong and if I am I will adjust
the pronunciation in future videos by
the way I am assuming that the spirit
guard is some sort of elite military
unit maybe the heart kingdoms equivalent
of the magic Knights or maybe it is the
Queen's own personal unit at any rate
Gaia recognizes mimosa from the previous
time that she visited the Hart Kingdom
and he states that mimosa left quite an
impression on them while she was here
the last time Noel also casually
mentions that Gaia is definitely a big
deal in the heart Kingdom which suggests
that he might be working directly for
the Queen herself Gaia proceeds to offer
everyone some crimson orange juice which
gets sweeter the more magic is added to
it
this is a pretty random use of magic but
it makes sense if we had magic in our
own world I'm sure that we would use it
for many silly things on top of more
important things like battling or
traveling etc I mean just look at all
the time we waste on all the countless
apps on our smartphones we certainly
don't use our phones just for making
calls
sure that if we had magic we would find
all sorts of ways of using it that isn't
really necessary to our lives but that
seems like a fun way to spend the time
and of course because this drink
requires magic to taste better
ah stays stuck asking others to make his
drink sweeter since he has no magic of
his own to add to the drink
FINRA asks Gaia where they are going
because they have seemingly arrived at a
dead end but Gaia explains that the
Queen will transport them personally as
he says this thereby confirming that he
is working on the orders of the Queen
directly an elevated liquid stairway
appears and carries the boat overland
and into another location Gaia explains
that this water stairway and all the fog
that surrounds the country are all part
of the Queen's massive mana zone but
Austin the others are shocked that just
one person could possess that much magic
the idea that one person can possess
enough mana to hide an entire country
and to create massive water stairways
from very long distances seems to
suggest that this Queen could be even
more powerful than Julius at his prime
and she is definitely more powerful than
the current chibi Julius as the clover
Kingdom visitors continue to marvel at
the beauty of the Hart Kingdom guy
explains that this country was created
1200 years ago back then the Queen
formed a pact to act as the water
priestess for a water spirit and she
uses the magic of this water spirit to
protect the kingdom in fact the Queen is
able to borrow the power of the
countless trees and abundant waters
which cover the kingdom in order to
foster the mana rich environment of the
kingdom itself the Queen's unique
abilities including her water spirit
magic have led to the development of a
very prosperous and advanced magical
civilization that lives in harmony with
nature
this revelation about the Queen confirms
that the entity which was shown floating
above the Queen in the previous chapter
was actually the water spirit and it
appears to be an extremely powerful and
highly developed elemental spirit at
that with all the talk in recent
chapters about demons and demon magic I
was thinking that this
entity may have been some sort of demon
as well but many people in the comments
of my previous videos pointed out that
it might be the water spirit and I know
that bro Kuno hero over on his channel
also accurately predicted that this
would be the water spirit so kudos to
all of you who caught on so quickly and
shoutout to broke we know hero as well I
will link his channel down in the
description below Noel is amazed by how
powerful this Queen seemingly is and
everyone is highly impressed by the fact
that the Queen has been able to bring
peace to an entire country on her own
but these revelations about the Queen
begged the following question is this
Queen the same Queen who established the
kingdom twelve hundred years ago or is
the screen a descendant of the original
Queen who found in the country assuming
that each Queen passed on the power of
the water spirit onto her daughter again
and again for twelve hundred years if
this is the case of a royal family
passing the power from one generation to
another then it makes sense in terms of
what we know about the world of black
clovers so far but if this is the same
person one Queen that has managed to
live for 1200 years we really have to
ask ourselves how she was able to live
for so long what kind of magic does she
have that allows her to basically become
immortal even though some creatures like
the devil and Sacre have been able to
survive over the course of hundreds of
years by using forbidden magic and even
though we've seen that reincarnation
magic is a possibility in the world of
black clover we have never heard of
anyone being able to live for over 1,000
years
if this Queen really has managed to live
for over a millennium it is both
extremely interesting and extremely
suspicious normal magic should not make
it possible for someone to become
immortal at least not as far as anything
we've been led to believe in the story
so far so if this Queen has lived for
this long
it suggests that she has been using some
very unconventional magic perhaps even
forbidden magic connected to a demon
perhaps she has been draining the mana
of the other people in the kingdom in
order to keep herself young or worse yet
perhaps she has been killing people and
sacrificing them in order to make a deal
with a demon and maybe the deal she
last four was eternal life we will have
to wait to find out but I'm definitely
getting some very suspicious and
mysterious vibes from this Queen and the
fact that she is so overpowered is just
one aspect of her mysterious aura then
suddenly hasta Anza cray in her bird
form are trapped inside a sphere of
water and rapidly thrown off the boat
and up into the air Noel mimosa and fin
roll are shocked by what just happened
and they demand an explanation from Gaia
but he simply says that there are
certain things that must be done for
peace finra mimosa noel immediately
follow after hasta using fin Rollins
spatial magic as a speed boost but even
though the three of them are now moving
extremely fast Gaia quickly catches up
as if it was nothing it also appears
that Gaia is able to float in the air
without using magic or at least without
using the conventional type of magic
that citizens of the clover kingdom are
familiar with in previous chapters it
was mentioned that different types of
magic are used in the heart kingdom
types of magic that are not necessarily
known in the clover kingdom so it is
likely that we are going to be learning
a lot more about all of that in the
coming chapters and I am definitely
looking forward to it
at this point Noel has had enough she
uses her Valkyrie dress to take on Gaia
furious that he dared to lay a hand on
asta a comrade of the clover Kingdom
royalty especially after they had come
all this way legally as official guests
and Noelle's
anger totally has nothing to do with the
fact that she likes austell or anything
you Bacchus so don't even think about
mentioning that down in the comments
gaia compliments Noelle's excellent
water magic noting to himself that it is
rare strong and certainly first-rate
Gaia then proceeds to say that he will
now also get serious and strange symbols
begin to float out of his grimoire
symbols that kind of look like a mixture
of Nordic runes and Greek letters but
before we can actually learn more about
Gaia strange magic we the readers are
transported to wherever Austen Sacre
have been taken inside that magical
water sphere Austen Sakura are thrown
down into some mass of abyss that makes
the Grand Canyon look
relatively tame by comparison and there
at the bottom of the abyss hasta comes
face to face with the Queen of Hearts
the Queen's real body appears to be a
shadow in the background as a giant
Knights armor made up of water magic
advances on hasta the queen says that
for the sake of her country she has been
waiting for Oscars demon and she appears
to be determined to take the demon magic
away from hasta presumably the Queen is
using her water spirit to attack us
while keeping her own bodies safe in the
distance at this point we don't actually
know if she'd had to kill asta or if she
just wants to steal his grimoire or if
she wants to do something else entirely
all we know is that the Queen has just
lured asta into a potentially deadly
trap and an epic battle seems to be
imminent
in the next chapter what's more it
doesn't seem like Noel memos and Finn
are all are going to be able to get Gaia
off their backs that easily he seems to
be hiding some tricks up his sleeve so
hasta will likely be on his own against
the Queen for the foreseeable future
unless Yami randomly shows up and wrecks
everyone but we'll have to wait and see
now in general this Queen seems to be
extremely powerful dedicated to her
country but also very interested in
demon power and determined to get it she
might be after the demon power for
devious reasons maybe she's possessed by
the demon or just interested in some
nefarious schemes but she might also be
trying to protect her kingdom
perhaps the Spade Kingdom is preparing
an attack on the Hart kingdom using the
power of the previously mentioned demon
Meggie Kula and so maybe the Queen of
Hearts believes that the only way to
defend herself and her kingdom is to
take Austin's demon power and use him to
make herself stronger if this was the
case then she wouldn't necessarily be
evil she is just willing to do whatever
it takes for the greater good of her
kingdom including luring Austin to a
trap and trying to take away his power
we'll have to wait and see although at
this point I'm leaning towards her not
being outright evil just interested in
protecting her Kingdom at any cost even
if that means doing immoral things to
others who didn't do anything wrong to
her my question is if this Queen is
really as powerful as she appears how
powerful would someone have to be to
pose a threat to her especially a threat
big enough to force her to lure
official guests from another Kingdom
into a trap and kidnap one of them with
the intention of stealing their power if
the Queen isn't just out for her own
interest and she's actually trying to
defend herself and her kingdom the
threat that she is trying to defend
herself from must be stronger than
anything we have seen up to this point
either way whether the Queen is evil or
just afraid of an even greater threat
the stakes are definitely being raised
sky-high in the black clover series
after a few fairly mild chapters
following the epic conclusion of the elf
saga it seems that we are now going to
be meeting characters who are as strong
as the kotodama devil or maybe even
stronger compared to what seems to be
happening now that whole damnatio thing
about the trial seems to be complete
child's play at any rate I can't wait to
see what happens next and my curiosity
about this overpowered Queen who
desperately wants Asta's demon has been
piqued let me know what you guys think
why does the Queen want Austen's demon
so desperately especially if she really
is as powerful as we think she is is she
evil is she possessed by a demon or is
she trying to protect her kingdom from
an even greater threat finally do you
think that the Queen is really over 1200
years old and if so how would that even
be possible in the world of black clover
please give me your thoughts down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more videos like it
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications feel free to follow me on
twitter and instagram at anime i'll pro
for all the latest black clover news and
updates I want to give a big thank you
to all of our anime out pro patrons who
make videos like this one possible
special thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King zelgius on Hal Cruz Steelers poet
Pablo
atropos Wraith very dolla beat a karate
GN Anatole Cassatt's ki DJ Nathaniel and
alpha do and I can't forget the ones
that rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons including in grata alone
Merrimack makoto-kun and your boys Seth
if you enjoy our videos and you think
that they add some value to your life
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us bass Cowboys
[Music]